speaking of changes of heart milo
yiannopoulos
milo yiannopoulos very famous right-wing
provocateur sort of famously gay
uh milo is now ex-gay
according to milo milo is saying he's
ex-gay he's
i think he's gay married but he's like
they're just not not doing that anymore
they're living together as roommates
and people are making fun of milo for
this is this a troll i don't maybe it is
i don't know milo is sort of a famous
performance artist so maybe he's just
kind of
he's just doing it as a publicity stunt
or something but i'm going to take it
seriously i'm going to say he actually
is going to be xk now what does that
mean he's not saying
that he's no longer sexually attracted
to men
he's not saying that he is now sexually
attracted to women
i mean just read the interview he's
explicitly not saying that he's saying
it's very difficult for him and he still
wants to
sleep with his housemate as he now calls
him
but he's saying i am choosing not to
indulge
in those desires and people are very
angry at milo for this
why would anyone be angry at milo for
this
why wha what is the pro what is it
any of your business just like people
always say what is it your business if
johnny wants to sleep with jack well on
the flip side
why is it any of your business if johnny
doesn't want to sleep with jack
if if we're told that we now can
construct our own sexual identities
why is it the case that the the sexual
identities can only go in one direction
why is it that it can only go in the
direction of indulging one's
natural desires why can't it go in the
other direction too if some guy comes
out and says you know
i've done that a lot i've done it for a
long time
but now as i've been thinking about it
and praying about it i
i don't want to do that anymore i i
my sort of mind does not want to do that
my
sort of more fleshly desires do want to
do that and so i'm going to try to
tame my fleshly desires because that in
my view is
is the right thing to do and so that's
what i want to do now
why would anybody be angry about that
milo yiannopoulos is now ex-gay
he says here is the interview it's in
life site news
he opens up and he says
secular attempts at recovery from sin
are either temporary or completely
ineffective
salvation can only be achieved through
devotion to christ and the works of the
holy catholic and apostolic church
so milo saying i'm catholic now
and i'm i'm reverting to my catholic
faith and
so i'm going to stop doing all this
other stuff is this just a troll
if it is a troll it's a it's a funny
troll right i mean it is
you've got this guy who is as
flamboyantly gay as anybody in public
life
and now he's saying nah i'm not doing
that anymore is that a troll
i actually have a reason to think that
it's not a troll
because being a catholic myself
milo and i run in some of the same
circles i don't really i don't know him
but i
we do know a number of people in common
and
i i've been hearing about this for a
while that milo is
sort of re-exploring his faith and sort
of taking his faith
catholic faith more seriously so i've
been hearing about this for months maybe
more
maybe even a couple years at this point
so i guess i was not quite as surprised
to see this interview as
some other people were he goes on he
says
i have enjoyed a lifeline a lifelong
affection for the absurd and the
outrageous
so part of me gleefully anticipates the
day i can seize the moral high ground
however briefly to denounce others for
failures of piety and sobriety
i hope people will support and pray for
me if for no other reason then they
share my delight at the prospect of milo
yiannopoulos
furiously and indignantly railing
against the homosexuals
for sins of the flesh that's a very
funny line again
sort of when you see these funny lines
you start to think hold on is this whole
interview just another
another performance but even if i mean
it's a funny interview regardless
even if it is you know milo is very
famous for trying on different
personalities
one day he's a buttoned up tweed wearing
brit the next day he's wearing you know
sort of big
stunner shades and a giant oversized
t-shirt and you know it's kind of more
hip-hop or something right he tries all
these things on
this does relate to forget the sexual
question for a moment
this does relate to the deeper religious
question
which is that in christianity
and and judaism for that matter god
god is i am right
what is god's name god responds i am
that i am
and christ in the new testament says
before abraham was i am so he's invoking
that he is
saying i i am god right by saying i am
the i am i
am the i am being itself
when a culture finds its identity
in i am
then things generally sort of are going
in the right direction
when a culture such as ours casts away
god and religion you are left with a
rather pitiful question which is
who am i you hear this kind of popular
phrase
well i've got to find myself you know
who am i one day on this one day on that
especially you see this with teenagers
right they're always trying on
new personalities trying on new
identities
uh because they're sort of adrift they
don't they're not they're not
basing it in this eternal fact of
of being himself then
milo concludes his interview he says
they say if you let one sin in others
will follow and now i truly know what
that means as i've begun to resist
sinful sexual urges i found myself
drinking less smoking less you name it
i confess my weakness for designer shoes
and handbags is
yet to dissipate but i'm coming to
realize however slowly
that lust per augustine is disorder
desire
for all sorts of things not just nfl
players
and uh so what he is espousing here is a
very
catholic point of view and the way this
story is going to be read is that he's
got some hang up or you know christians
have some hang up
on homosexuality but it's really not the
case at least in the
traditional catholic sexual ethic
it's not just it's not just milo's
sexual desires that are off limits it's
a whole host of them because
we the catholics believe that sex has to
be ordered
toward a purpose right so
those sort of things that you do when
you close the blinds and you're alone at
night you know that
that's off limits uh having sex without
the
uh possibility of creating life
without without i'm sorry without the
physical possibility of creating life
that's off limits uh it's a very
it's a very uh focused kind of sexual
morality
chesterton observed he said you know the
one thing that kind of got me curious
about the church
is that it would get attacked for
opposite reasons on the one hand it's
too ascetic right and just on this
particular
rigorous sexual morality but on the
other hand it's too luxurious there's
the gold of saint peter's and all this
beautiful art and
all the fancy clothes and everything
gets attacked for opposite points of
view
i mention this whole story not because i
am particularly interested
in milo's sex life i mention it
because of a political question that it
brings up
it reveals the left's real view
of sexual preference and sexual openness
and sexual tolerance
we are told in this society of ours
that we must tolerate people's sexual
behaviors
regardless of our own moral views
whatever they want to do we should
tolerate that
okay i i see the argument for that
so what about milos so what about my
we if you're telling me i'm fine i'm
i'll i'm i'm in we're gonna tolerate
people's sexual
behaviors even though even still there
are some things that are off limits but
who knows how long they'll be off limits
we're going to tolerate people's sexual
behaviors whatever they want to do
not ours to judge well then what about
milos
milo is saying this is this is my
preferred sexual behavior now i don't
i want to be chased and basically not
engaged in sex
because his sexual desires are such that
he doesn't want to indulge them
isn't that good isn't that a good thing
isn't that according to i'm not even
saying according to the catholic logic
i'm saying according to the logic of the
left
isn't that a good thing but it never
cuts that way because the principles
that the left is espousing
are are really not principles so much as
they're creating
a new a new order of society
it's not these universal principles of
tolerance and acceptance
just a new order for society it reminds
me of people attacking mike pence for
not cheating on his wife do you remember
that
they were really upset a few years ago
because it came out that mike pence
would not have dinner dates with women
when his wife wasn't present i kid you
not i had liberal friends of mine
this was before the metoo movement they
were angry with me they said it's awful
that mike pence won't
go on dinner dates with his staff and
with other women
it's not fair it's sexist then five
seconds later the metoo movement starts
and mike pence is looking pretty good
right but no because he's kind of damned
if he doesn't damned if he doesn't
there's no there's no fair standard
that's going to apply if you enjoyed
that video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there
[Music]
[Music]